check this out
[Music]
meme review i didn't get no [ __ ]
i love me
two guys on a bus
this originated apparently with the some
it's a spanish origin
spanish brothers would be like that's
beautiful then of course the internet
takes their own spin on it suplex
i don't get it
hayao miyasaki
i get this one i understand it i laugh
because i understand and
the off chance that some people don't
make me feel good
it's good versus evil memes i get it too
it's a plato's cave why would that be a
meme
look everyone's happy
but only he who break out of cave can be
truly happy come on
[Laughter]
lost me made me laugh in 2020 i don't
even know what year it is they don't
know i'm on the bus too damn
entering the chasm
good morning i know i'm gonna blackmail
the transit system it's automated these
are very specific references that's
probably why i didn't get the first one
yes
people told me there's a new variant
it's like bro i found out about delta a
month ago like bruh
i like this meme that i wanted to buy
thing before leaving the house
read it and we
radical liberals who romanticize them
shut up oh my god yeah dammit
[Laughter]
there's some intellectual memes
happening yep
london subway right there that's pretty
good i enjoy that meme
i'm gonna rate it high i'll rate it an
eight had a good lie well done two guys
on the bus huh who would have thought
gabe you know what it is next meme let's
go
he's 12. it's damn
that's a thumbnail that's a that's an
actual thumbnail someone uploaded that
onto youtube
that exists on youtube cool that's
awesome
[Laughter]
oh that means he's 14.
damn yeah see girls do it too
it's guts from bernstein he's six
damn
she's he what
i want to see the god damien why is the
crop oh my god is that him he's 31 zam
i like that castrate it's a good
carefree he's 14. damn yeah she is kind
of thirsting over him it's kind of weird
i never thought about that i watched it
so long ago also everyone asuka he's
actually 13 i didn't know that
damn
what the [ __ ] i know you succeeded me
not that that's better
zam zam
what the [ __ ] but bro the episode came
out in 1995.
it's cool she old there it's cool zam
[ __ ] japanese getting me canceled
she's now
zayn
mm-hmm 41.
it's a spy from team fortress bloody
hell 41 then she's a thousand zam
uh
they're not undertale
all right i understand the direction now
yeah okay
mm-hmm
god damn she's a legend of them no
that one is cursed
stop it whoever posted that should feel
bad
another classic catchphrase that is the
damn is of course damn daniel making a
return
i've seen this i didn't know what's a
meme so it's just confusing as hell
[Music]
oh my god
did memes used to be good
no
no they didn't but they weren't this bad
things were not this bad i swear
damn daniel
[Music]
hey
okay
[Music]
damn daniel
okay that's enough that's enough stop it
all right
that's it for this week's meme review
do we have time for yes we do
[Music]
no older meme but it makes me laugh it's
a classic take on the boys versus girl
meme we have a girl here with autism
doing a little
wiggly thing
it's kind of sweet
let's go champ
me beat his personal record man oh yeah
yeah like with silly yelling about the
bro
all right we have the tyler version
i'm sure there's a perfect context to
explain this i don't want to know it
though
[Music]
hey excuse me sir do you know where the
cameras are oh yeah come over here okay
hey hey come over here bro hey what the
[ __ ] the cameras i'm trying to look for
the cameras
let the man go hey where's the camera
where the camera is
why is he running like he's part of a
musical
[Music]
[Laughter]
don't do it
no
ah forbidden
[Music]
the excited little hands thing always
gets to me is that that
let's go james
[Music]
all right that last meme was was for
zazz thank you for
watching another episode of meme review
that was a scene meme review show of all
time thank you very much thank you it's
been an honor a pleasure
zanz no that wasn't it zam